hopefully a little deeper into the ball
game today for luke weaver with the same
stuff weaver on the mound diamondbacks
and dodgers the third of a four game set
from downtown phoenix glad you're with
us on fox sports arizona here's max
muncie
97 luke weaver attacking with that
fastball and he strikes out max muncie
riding a five-game hitting streak
hitting 256 with a home run and five
runs batted in payoff pitch
this one is hit in the air to right
center field
on the run look castro and he can't hang
on
and betts
into second base easily with a one-out
double corey seeger's home runs purr at
bat and the 2018 was the injured season
so we didn't take that ratio but
everything else right around one every
25 at bats well this year about one
every 10.
off of weaver they got to find it watch
bets coming around third
they do get the out at first and mookie
stays put down there and let's see if
luke's okay comes ryan de panfalo to
have a look point everything seeger hits
is right on the barrel a nice play to
get the out at first look like mark
burley shoveling on defense
that's a heck of a defensive play right
there it really is and they get seeger
by his step luke says he's okay
tremendous recovery right there they
will face left-hander julio urias who
makes his second start of this 2020
season marty is seven for 24 to start
the year two rbis a pair of doubles four
walks he has the diamondbacks lone
stolen base at the pitch a drive to left
field and heading over and having to
play it on a hop out there is a left
fielder peterson he'll get it back in
and stop in at second on the play is
vargas a base hit for starly marte two
on now one out for eduardo escobar
up the middle and throw into center
vargas had to hold up a little stutter
step there that'll get the run home
escobar with the rbi single d-back
strike first d-back's on the board early
gotta love that
again the 3-2
appealed at first base he got him adrian
johnson
brings up walker on a check swing that
went a little too far batting average
trending back up for david peralta who
collected his gold glove award before
the game now aureus is 28th pitch here
it comes fastball swung on and miss
strike three that ends the end jock is
three for 14 and 0 for his last six
shift on the right side and peterson
down swinging
here is rios
swing and a miss good change up there
from luke he's got a good one so far
tonight that's his third strikeout and
this is a position in which matt beatty
seemed to excel last year he had a knack
for getting that big hit it almost 380
last season with runners in scoring
position no two pitched to matt beatty
and he got him swinging four strikeout
weaver leaves him out having struck out
the side we head to the third inning one
nothing diamondbacks top of the order
here against luke weaver max muncie
swing and a miss weaver humps it up to
96 and that's five strikeouts for luke
weaver he's got muncie twice the
dangerous mookie bets a double in his
first at-bat tonight
another one off the bat a mookie bet
starling martez got it
everything's a rocket off the bat of
bets in this series and starling got
there just deep enough to get to it 32
at bats to get three home runs quickest
before this in a year was 2017 65 at
bats
left field and it is going to be off the
wall peralta hurries it back in but it's
a two-out stand-up double for corey
seeger
it's his third two base hit of the young
season top of the order will start at
the bottom of the third against lefty
julio orios it's katel marte who
grounded out to start the ball game
down on strikes
and that is the first out of the third
and the third strike out of the game
edwin
and smith and beatty not in there every
day so they got to take advantage of
this opportunity not only for the team
but for themselves
as edwin hits one high and deep to right
center
this ball back and it is
gone a home run edwin rios
a two run shot and the dodgers
are in front two to one no doubter for
rios his second of the season his swing
when he hits it solid it becomes a no
doubter he lifts and separates look at
that beautiful follow through six home
runs in 54 big league packs
is that any good that's world record
pace
trying to get into the act and he hits
one down the right field line near the
pole it is gone into the bullpen
matt beatty
makes it 3-1 with his first home run of
the season christian walker a strikeout
victim in the first
coming back to score 26 runs so far 18
coming in the sixth inning or later
walker trying to change that trend
that's off the wall in the corner
peterson fishes it out and christian
stops at second with a double what's up
to carson kelly he's got walker at
second with two outs
carson kelly knocks that into right
center they're gonna send christian
walker
the rbi for carson
seeger one for two
picked up his third double of the year
in the third inning
and this one is belted into right for a
base hit
vance is going to continue on to third
turns on the jets he is locked in he
loves first pitches he even loves him
even more when he is locked in the way
he is despite missing most of
2018 corey is still ninth in the big
leagues
as far as putting the ball in play and
oo counts
justin turner looking for a hit over two
tonight 2-1 pit
and this ball is hit high in the air
toward right center field and date
it is off the wall
bets will score
seeger rumbling around the bases
and he will score and into second with a
two-run double is justin turner eighth
hit for the dodgers a.j pollock
swings and hits a drive to the left
and this ball is gone a home run aj
pollock his second of the season a two
run shot two more on the board for los
angeles
and then aj pollock said jacques you
don't have to run
i'll just take care of this myself and
paul was kissed